欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一章节我们来讲一下
我们的产品要卖给谁更容易成交
这个板块主要是让我们学会如何去分析买家
因为作为一个运营,如果你不知道买家是谁
你不知道买家有哪些特性或者是偏好或者是他的一些特质
那么你在做产品详情业主图以及帮户首页的时候
你都是很难有针对性的去营销这些客户的
如果你没有针对性去满足这些客户
或者是说你没有把买家想要看到的内容和他所需要解决的问题的方法呈现出来
那么这个买家就很难给你发寻盘
就会导致很多买家的一个流失
只有访客没有寻盘
没有寻盘就是这种情况
所以我们一定要知道我们的客户是谁
他们喜欢什么样的产品
或者是说他们有什么样的特征需求等等
一定要多维度的去分析
这样的话
你的运营的综合技能才能更加的扎实
不然你只是在操作细节
或者是说运营的层面
去提升这个店铺
那么这个还是有一定的局限性的
我们要有买家思维
买家思维才能够让我们的技能提升的更快
让我们的店铺的效果做得更加明显的提升
所以我们要把好的产品卖给有需求的人才更加容易成交
我们不要把那些产品卖给所有人
而是要把产品卖给有需求的人
也就是我们在推广的时候
要把我们的产品推广给更加有需求的人
或者是更加匹配我们产品的这一类买家
那么你的转化率才会更高
既然我们都需要去找这些有需求的买家
那么我们怎么样去找呢
第一个
如果你们公司是已经有很多年线下成交客户的一些数据
或者是说公司已经总结了很多关于客户的文档
以及客户的分析的一些文档
大家去学习一下
我们这个产品
它对应的客户是哪一类
客户批发商呢
还是零售商
它有什么样的特征
它所需要的产品是用于解决什么问题
我们能够在产品详尖页
怎么样凸显我们的优势
来帮它解决这个问题
这个产品的详尖页
以及你去推广的时候
才能把握的更加清楚
所以说
我们在操作店铺之前
或者是在操作的过程中
我们要多去了解我们的买家
这是线下的
第二类
我们后台不是有一些寻盘吗
加上一些客户的列表是吧
这些都有吧
我们点进去看
我们去归纳
总结一下
我们这些客户的一些
相同的属性
比如说
你的寻盘L1
或者是说
成交比较多的那种客户的
账号类型
它的买家账号
类型是怎么样的
你去总结一下这些规律
而不是一直盲目的去干
我们一定要去总结它的这些账号
有什么特征
有什么规律
总结一下它的一个行业偏好
或者是说
它的属性啊
年限啊
这些都可以去分析
那么你这样去分析之后
就能够形成一个客户的画像
客户画像
这个时候
你后期在做推广详情页
旺铺首页
装修这些
都有一个非常精准的参考
你去谈客户的时候
也是参考这些他的需求去谈的
而不是说我们凭自己的感觉去跟客户沟通
我们肯定是基于买家的需求
去跟他沟通
去帮助他解决问题
才能更容易成交
如果你是一个运营
一定要学会分析一下买家
做一些数据的表格
把他的画像尽可能的清晰的描述出来
工作方面就会非常的高效
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再讲其他的板块